uh pro startup anti-big tech that is a
very very popular narrative today
i think you've said you can't really
have
that stance like those are
contradictions to each other being pro
startup and anti-tech
or anti-big tech how do you kind of
settle that or balance that that idea
yeah i mean the the whole idea of like
what we do at bedrock what i do
is we were investing in these super
early companies sometimes it's just
um a few a few ladies in a in an
apartment in brooklyn where they're
where they're quarantined uh working on
coding something to get coding something
up
and uh and it's really just a bet on the
people and uh and
and and the idea and the market
opportunity
and implicit in doing that you have to
believe that it will one day be a big
tech company
and so implicit in doing the early stage
startup investing
in order to have that be a profitable
endeavor
um one has to believe that some of the
companies that you're investing in when
it's just a few
you know uh men ladies um
you know uh um whatever
however anyone wants to identify you
know their gender you know a few people
working together on something
um when there's really nothing other
than just their vision
them their like raw abilities and a
market opportunity and you're giving
them you're writing them a chat
just based on that you've got to believe
like implicit that
you you hope that one day will be a huge
tech company and so
i find it like this very convenient but
like completely incoherent position when
i see
technology investors who are just
categorically like we have to break up
all the big tech companies
all the big tech companies are evil but
make their livings
by investing in these early stage tech
startups like that to me just seems like
an incoherent position
and there actually are more than a few
again i don't
view myself as a venture capitalist i'm
a i'm an investor
you know some people get to
self-identify as vcs
i just self-identify as an investor um
that's my personal identity and i'm
laying claim to that
but uh but um but certain vcs
uh certain vc's out there are pretty
vocal about the fact they they think all
the big tech companies are evil and need
to be
government broken up by the government
but are but are making their living off
investing in startups and
and that feels very incoherent now
that's not to say
that some of the big com tech companies
have done bad things and deserve to pay
a price for
for doing those things but i don't think
being categorically anti-big tech is a
coherent
is a coherent position well and it leads
to this
um kind of thing that people forget
which is that every
challenger or disruptor if successful
becomes the man
right so i think that's kind of your
point here and we're seeing this play
out perfectly with
apple vs uh fortnite and apple
is you know they used to be the the
people in the garage right they were the
ones who were gonna go disrupt the uh
the tech world and kind of
um the computer science and software
world
now everyone's pointing the finger
saying you're the big bad person who's
you know
preventing me from running my business
the way i want to run my business and so
how do you analyze fortnite
versus apple i know you called uh
fortnite's uh
thing the uh the greatest corporate um
propaganda ever uh i tend to think when
i saw it but it was
absolutely awesome that the way they
kind of executed this whole thing
but but talk a little bit just about
that that showdown between
you know two really just heavy weights
and um over
uh over the financial relationship that
they have
yeah i mean um it it is uh
it's uh it was a brilliant move by
fortnight you basically have the
situation where you have
apple um you have apple
uh has been this just really important
distribution channel
um for for these for these for these
companies these games these businesses
and um and uh and the reality is that um
the reality is that uh
sorry the reality is that when you when
you're when you're generating the demand
as fortnight's fortnite's doing um when
you're generating the demand
um uh um you
you you you're able to capture you're
able to capture the
to capture more of the value and so
there's this um
there's this 30 tax that that fortnite
has to pay apple
um that epic has to pay apple that
fortnight on the app store
and um and and yet they're able to
generate their demand for fortnite
via all these different paths you know
they've got consoles they've got
other um other dev other other mobile
devices
um all sorts of ways people can engage
with fortnite
they are not to completely path
dependent on ios
um and um and um and so there's a sense
in which you know my partner eric
stromberg has this
my partner at bedrock has this great
website street screenshot essays.com
and he would sort of i think term the
app store
like it's becoming more of a dumb pipe
for media companies
like epic like fortnite um uh because uh
because um they just have the leverage
to negotiate down the tax
uh they're not fully path dependent on
the app store
and so you know as eric says epic was
the first to make a move here but
they're not going to be the last
yeah i i also loved the whole um
it was such bait right it basically was
like let's negotiate let's negotiate
less negotiate okay you're not gonna
cave
they just waited and it's very obvious
they had the lawsuits ready they had the
marketing video ready
like everything was lined up and they
went ahead and they just said we're
gonna do it anyways
and then uh i didn't know this until
recently they actually sent an
email to apple saying we just did this
so they didn't even wait for apple to go
find it like they basically like
you know said to him you know we're
putting the middle finger up apple took
them off and then that's when they kind
of unleashed everything
and look that's like that's something
you would have expected from apple 30
years ago